Speaker 1: All right. I have some Dr. Oz Geiger
cringe for you today. This is I. I have never seen
anything like this. This is maybe the most awkward
moment from any political rally I've ever seen
short of when Trump a few weeks ago tried to kiss
that swimmer and she kind of like just tried to
get away from. Mehmet Oz is a television doctor.
And, of course, as we spoke about earlier and as
as we have been speaking about, he's running in
Pennsylvania for the Senate. He's the Republican
nominee. His opponent is John Fetterman. I
would suggest voting for John Fetterman. I think
Fetterman is a better candidate. And there
was a guy who wanted to ask Oz about abortion.
And Dr. Oz puts straps, a blood pressure cuff to
the guy. And I don't think I've ever seen anything
this bizarre. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Tell me a little bit
about yourself. Well, so often. Abortion? Yes.
Speaker 1: You know, while I take your blood
pressure, I will answer that question, sir.
Speaker 2:
Well. Well, you know, is there a limit to it
or is there a, you know, a time when women
should be allowed to get an abortion? Or is it.
Speaker 1: This is an issue that really affects
this man significantly? You can tell.
Speaker 2: Should we ban it altogether?
Speaker 5: I honestly so as you all probably
know, I'm pro-life, but I have three exceptions
and I spoke about them a lot in the primary.
I'm a doctor. I appreciate the realities of
taking care of people who are
struggling. Don't get nervous.
So. So I think the life of the mother, rape,
incest, these are problems that I think families
should have the ability to deal with. And it's
hard to expect the government to deal with.
Speaker 1: Now, what in God's name is happening
in this country, folks? If Fetterman doesn't
win this one, I might have to end the show and
leave the political world and just kind of go
out into the woods and just live a some kind of
primitive life. Because, I mean, and actually,
if Oz or Herschel Walker win, I'm going to
need to go and have a deep think about my life
beyond just being bizarre. What doctor takes
blood pressure when someone's legs are crossed
and they're talking and while they're
holding their arm up in the air, I mean,
it just it's terrible blood pressure technique.
Wasn't he a cardiac surgeon? He should know this
stuff. And politically, here's another
very strange moment from the same rally
where Oz compares homeless people to zombies with
needles sticking out of their necks. And you can
just tell he would be an empathetic senator.
Speaker 5: You go down to downtown Philadelphia.
I see a little bit in Pittsburgh
now, too, but more in Philadelphia.
Speaker 1: I seen it. There are.
Speaker 5: Whole blocks. I mean,
like multiple blocks in areas you can't go there.
Addicts walking like zombies, you know, into the
streets with needles sticking out of their necks.
Speaker 1: Really just vivid imagery there for
Mehmet Oz. This guy is horrible. I mean, truly,
truly horrible. And he has no business being
in the United States Senate if you look at
people currently running. Are there. I mean,
I would say any random schoolteacher would be
better for the country as one of the 100 members
of the United States Senate than Mehmet Oz or
Herschel Walker. These seem like two of the worst
people, just not worse candidates. Just if you
said to me, David, who would be bad people to
be in the Senate, I would say, well, Herschel
Walker would be terrible. And Mehmet Oz would
be terrible to be in with these people shouldn't
be anywhere near the Senate. And yet they could
end up collectively making up 2%. Right. 1/50 of
the Senate. Let's hope that that doesn't happen